>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Ragnar Almqvist:
Ireland is fortunate
to have a rich literary heritage.
Over the centuries our writers
have enlarged our country's global
footprint and embedded images
of Ireland and its people
in the imaginations
of readers everywhere.
Colm Toibin stands firmly
in this proud tradition.
What I especially admire about
his work is its immense variety.
He's renowned for his
Wexford novels,
which are set in the
county was birth,
but his work has an immense range
with novels like The Master,
The Testament of Mary,
and most recently House
of Names stretching his
imagination well beyond the bounds
of his own home place
and personal experience.
He has made important
contributions to literary criticism
through his writings on Elizabeth
Bishop and Augusta Gregory,
and as any reader of
the New York Review
of Books will attest is
amongst the best essayist
in the English language.
Finally, Colm has contributed
to the public life of Ireland
as a journalist and critic with
his perceptive analyses off.
for example, the Easter rising
and it's centenary last year.
He is an artist of profound gifts.
To the ambassadors words I
might add in the four years
since I last met him,
Colm has also found time
to write a Tony nominated play for
Broadway, see his work translated
to the silver screen, and nominated
for best picture at the Oscars
and in the past few months
co-curated an exhibition
of American painting
at the Morgan Library.
He is a virtuoso and celebrated
as such the world over.
Translated into more than 30
languages he has won almost
as many major literary
prizes and being shortlisted
for countless more including
three times the Booker Prize.
And later this year, the Dayton
Literary Peace Prize will present
him with their lifetime
achievement award named
after the US diplomats
Richard C. Holbrooke.
In recognition of Colm's
writings, social impact,
and that impact has been
profound, ladies and gentlemen,
because as well as being one of
our nation's greatest writers
as our ambassador noted,
Colm has also been one
of its sharpest critics, and indeed
a catalyst for its social change.
Bad Blood is akin [phonetic]
to walking the border
between Northern Ireland
and the Republic in 1986,
capture attentions,
contradictions, personal tragedies
of a troubled time in Irish history.
And The Blackwater Lightship
and other writings his unsentimental
depiction of what it then meant
to be gay in Ireland
contributed in no small way
to changing what it now
means to be gay in Ireland.
In May 2015 days before the Irish
people became the first in the world
to embrace marriage
equality by popular vote,
Colm gave a public
lecture at Trinity College,
titled The Embrace of Love.
On the grounds were
Oscar Wilde was educated,
there could've been no more eloquent
or impactful case for equality.
But in case I misrepresent
them, let me correct myself.
Though he has written
from the perspective
of the Virgin Mary,
Colm is no saint.
A piece in the Telegraph some
years ago described him as austere
in writing, wicked in person.
As a reader of his work, as
an admirer of his sentences,
I would dispute the former,
but having been lucky enough
to spend some evenings
in his company,
I can confirm that the latter
is true in the very best sense.
Our ambassadors had the pleasure
of interviewing Colm several
times before and asked me
to finish this afternoon
by telling you all
that you have a great
treat in store.
I believe that at the end of Com's
remarks there will be an opportunity
for you to pose questions,
and I want to remind you
at 2:30 you can do yourself a
very great favor and have one
of not only Ireland's
but the world's great writers
sign your copy of House of Names.
So with that please join
me in welcoming Colm Toibin
to the National Book Festival.
[ Applause ]
>> Colm Toibin: Thank you very much.
If only he would say that
at home, it would be great.
The problem began when I finished
the novel called The Blackwater
Lightship which was set in Ireland
in 1993 over six or seven days
with only six or seven characters.
There was a lot of rain, there
was a lot of making of tea,
there was just a lot of the
inner workings of an Irish family
which meant a lot of things that had
never been said were still not being
said, but everyone was sort of
sitting there brooding about them.
And every so often the grandmother,
who was no help, would try
and introduce the most dangerous
topic into the conversation
to see what trouble, more
trouble she could now cause
and since it was her house as she
said herself in the book, I'm old
and I'll say what I like.
The problem was what to do now
because I felt I had written
myself out of the Irish family.
I felt I had written myself out
of rain, of cups of tea you,
of days like that, and I had
a choice and the choice was
between writing another such novel
or writing a novel
about Henry James.
And then if I wrote a novel
about Henry James it would be,
the research would involve
going to Venice, you know,
going to Rome trying to
research the inner lives,
and indeed the outer apparel
of duchesses and lords
and ladies and grand parties.
And on the other hand if
I went back to Ireland,
I'll be back in the small house,
the rain outside and the tea inside
and one of the things I discovered,
which I didn't almost know
when I was, when I started
The Blackwater Lightship was
that whole idea of what women's
voices in a country like Ireland
where there has been so much
repression of various sorts,
what women's voices do when
there is an opening for them.
And I am, when I went on to
finally write a novel after that
which was set in Ireland which is
called Nora Webster and a novel
in between which is called Brooklyn,
I realized I had written three
novels which were written
about women and about women
speaking, about women silences
and in Ireland in the
years from the 1950s
into the 1990s I suppose
the memory would be
that if upstairs there were three
or four women in my mother's bedroom
and downstairs were three or
four men in the room below
and I'm a little boy moving
between the two spaces,
upstairs no matter what the women
are talking about and usually it was
about a coat that Auntie Harriet
almost bought in Dublin and didn't
in the end even though it under
sale in clearies [phonetic]
and she went back twice to fit it
on and that Auntie Maeve would say,
well, was it the buttons?
And she would say, no, I don't know
what it was and my mother might say,
oh, well you could go back again.
She said, no, it is gone.
I went back another time it
had gone and they would go on,
and I would look from one
to the other about the coat
that was almost bought by Auntie
Harriett, and I would know also
from because I was
very good at listening
to what they were really saying
was that there was an argument.
My mother was in a rage with one or
other or both or all of her sisters,
but they were not mentioning
the rage.
I was wondering at what moment was
my mother going to say well, but no,
it was going to be about a
blouse that my mother had,
but it didn't really
fit her anymore.
She wondered if she could swap that
for something that Auntie Maeve had
and it would go, and then
I would go downstairs
and there would be the four me
sitting and one of them would say
to the other that second
goal on Sunday was good.
It was a good goal.
And there would be general silence
and they all smoked cigarettes
as they consider the goal
and a man would say that,
but wasn't the second goal was good?
And the others would say it was good
that second goal, and you'd look
at the four of them and
think are they going to say,
is there anything more going
to occur as these people,
I mean in other words,
Beckett was a social realist.
One of them could he's
a good player all right
and they would nod
solemnly, silently daring you
to say anything else and then
someone would say but his brother,
his brother he had it in him as
well, and they'd say, ah, he did,
but he didn't do, and then there
be a big discussion the brother
and the difference between
the brother and him.
And you go back upstairs
to find that my mother had,
Auntie got her entire wardrobe
and had arranged a swap
of everything she didn't like
for stuff that Auntie Maeve had,
and you'd realize that that
whole idea of if the difference
if a woman came to the
house who wasn't one
of the aunts she could sit
for the whole evening talking
about something and if
a man came he could sit
for the whole evening just looking
straight ahead of him saying
that no, he wouldn't have more
tea, he didn't he would, he might,
and that might be the nearest
thing to drama the difference
between the fact that he
would, he wouldn't or he might.
And that's the world
we lived in and so
that you could put
it into the books.
So the problem then
was that I wrote,
it's like what Alice
McDermott has been saying
that you always feel you're
constantly despite the best help
of Irish diplomats that you're about
to be found out and that phone call
of the encounter with the
editor will be the end of you
or they will say it, you know,
this book really, really no,
and you'd say, well,
it's fine, don't worry.
I wonder if it's about,
and I'm not going to say,
I'm not going to use the C word, the
colonized word, but I wonder if it's
about poverty or some
sort of strange sense
of no matter what you do you
going to be fired from your job
on your house is going to burn
or the English are going to come
or something is going
to happen to you
or worst the English
are not going to come,
you're going to have to go to them.
You know in other words
emigration that you think
if you did anything
really wrong at home,
someone did something very wrong
that say, ah, he went to England.
Or in the case of a woman it
would even be more telling.
Ah, she had to go to
England you know what I mean?
And so that whole sense that at
any moment something could occur
that you always need to have
a second book almost finished.
So if the editor says look give this
up, this Henry James nonsense is not
for you, and who do
you think you are?
You say, oh, actually I have
another little Irish book waiting
so that sense that you
almost, you always need
to be working on two books.
I mean what Alice McDermott said
about Jonathan Galassi you live
in fear of the phone call and
you always know what to do,
oh no, it's fine, don't worry.
I don't like it either and that
in fact I have another book,
I think the other book
would be, you know.
And so in the spring 2000
I began, I began two novels
and with the opening of the
Henry James novel I was able
to describe a moment in
the life of Henry James
but he has an absolute
disaster in the theatre.
We know a great deal about him
because he who wrote great numbers
of letters about how he hoped to
have a huge success in the theatre
and many of his friends who were
in the audience they left reports
of what the opening night was like.
And he went to a play by Oscar Wilde
while his own play was going on.
He didn't like the Oscar Wilde play
and then he walked across the square
to his own play, which
is coming to an end.
He heard the applause,
he heard shouting,
but he thought it was
shutting of approval.
He didn't know that towards the
end of his play there was a line
which he put so much thought into,
they're always the worst lines,
the ones that you think there was a
line where one of the characters has
to say I am the last, My Lord, of
the Domvilles [phonetic] and a woman
from the back from the [inaudible]
shouted it's a bloody good thing
you are.
And the audience started
to yell, cat call
and every possible sort
of insult at the actors.
And the main actor who had
paid all the money for this
and decided what he would do
in retaliation was bring
Henry James onto the stage.
Just let him feel what they been
feeling for the last 10 minutes.
James thought he was coming on for
a curtain quality author and even
at the beginning he didn't
know what to do but he bowed
and the audience didn't
like the way he bowed.
There was a sort of pride, sort of
insolence in it so they cat called
and yelled further, all friends
you know in the nonpaying part
of the place they applauded, the
others just yelled abuse at him.
And I have no problem writing this
because as Ragnar mentioned I
have been shortlisted three times
for the theater of cruelty
known as the Man Booker Prize.
And so just before I began to
write this sequence I found myself
shortlisted for the first time and
that is very exciting because I was
in London when it happened and
didn't know until I went back
to Ireland that, when I went back
to Ireland the first Saturday
people would stop their cars and get
out of their cars and go, yeah, like
I was sort of running for Ireland
or I was an athlete of some sort.
I mean I had just written a book.
Then when the main thing, my mother
always said the main thing to do
but before you go out ever
is to wash under your arms.
And so before I went to London
for the Booker Prize I washed
under my arms, and I got a suit
and, you know, I did wash more than,
I mean I washed all of myself
really to be to be true,
and I put on a monkey suit.
It was going to be great and
the funny thing is about us
as humans no matter what
happens we continue hoping.
It should have been clear to me
that a novel about six Irish people
over six days, you know,
where they would just make tea
and tell stories was never
going to win anything.
I think they just put it the short
list because they felt sorry for it,
but anyway as the moment came up
where I was actually sure that I had
and I had a speech ready
thanking everyone and, you know,
going on about the importance
of reading, and I was going
to be really earnest about the
world then someone else won.
The thing is just before, when I say
just before I mean an hour before
as you're eating your dinner six TV
crews go to six shortlisted writers
and they put a camera in your face
and the closer the camera comes
to your face the more sure
you are you won the prize
and you keep saying to
everyone beside you look, look,
it's coming right in on me.
And then, of course, the minute you
don't win they just turn the lights
off on you complete.
So it's almost as though
the light had been on you
for so long you think
you're now in the dark
and people are literally
afraid to be seen with you.
If you go to the men's bathroom,
men will not do what
they must do besides you.
You have to go into the place
where you lock the door and just,
you know, doing that and then
as you're walking out people
who you know well just slip by you
and you then go out on the street
and you think, oh,
God, it's too late
to get the last flight
back to Dublin.
I have to be in London.
What was I ever doing here?
So I gave all those
emotions to Henry James
on it was very, very
useful experience.
If I had won, I would've known what
to do whereas losing was just great
because I could make Henry,
you know, give that disaster
that occurred to me to I
could give it to Henry James.
But the other novel that
I started became the novel
which was called Nora Webster, and
I started it in the spring of 2000.
I keep promising myself to add to it
and every summer I would add a bit,
I would erase a bit, it was
really the story of what happened
in our house in the three or
four years after my father died
between 1967 and 1972 when I was
12 and my younger brother was 8
and my mother was there and so the
three of us were there in the house
as we attempted to rebuild our
world in the absence of my father
as my mother found a job, as myself
and my younger brother worked
out what we could and couldn't say
or what the silence was really like
or the fact that the silences
were so filled with things.
And every year as I
said I would add to it,
but also every year I would
do anything not to add to it.
So if anyone invited
me anywhere I would go.
So I was anybody.
So I went to Texas, and I went
to Austin [phonetic] to teach
for a semester instead of writing
my book and Austin is great.
I mean people really
in Austin love Austin.
There are big stickers
of Keep Austin Weird
and they're really proud of
Austin and it's changed a lot.
I mean this was in 2006
2007, so it's changed a bit,
but felt about it like Brendan
[inaudible] felt about Toronto,
you know, they arrested
Brendan in Toronto.
So he took against the place
and when he was leaving they asked
him what he thought of Toronto.
He said, ah, it will be
lovely when you finish it.
So I mean I felt the same a
bit about Austin, you know,
the one side of the
street was there but the
where was the other
side of the street?
I felt homesick.
I wanted to go home.
I think that I don't even like in
Ireland, you know, Irish bread,
Irish weather, the
Irish news, Irish radio.
Things that I despise
in Ireland really.
I would lie in bed in the morning
in Austin and wish I was at home
in Ireland or at least
had the choice
where at least I had
some Irish bread nearby.
So the idea, here was I, you
know, 50 or something years old,
feeling homesick and the idea
of, you know, missing things
and crossing off the days
and realizing December
I'll be going home, home.
Suddenly I knew what home was.
When I went home, I thought I
really have to go back to this book.
And so I went back
to work on the novel,
which became the novel Nora Webster,
and am in the first few
pages I found the story.
I needed to put in something
about visitors coming to the house
that in the aftermath of my
father's death, which would happen
at home it was very common, the
house would be filled with people
and be filled with people
talking and they would obviously
at the beginning express sympathy
and they would be very soft,
but then the conversation could
go on about any other topic.
It was an amazing gift
to a novelist.
This little 12-year-old sat
and listened to all of them
and one evening a woman
came and she talked
about her daughter in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn wasn't America,
it wasn't Manhattan,
it wasn't New York, it was Brooklyn.
And she had letters from
her and things from her
and often the most interesting part
of the evening was when the person,
someone left the house and
the others would start talking
about them and you'd find out
something really interesting usually
if you listened carefully.
Often you'd be put out of the room
eventually when something very,
very private was being told,
but if you just sat there quietly
you'd hear, and I heard the story
that the woman's daughter
had come back from Brooklyn
and that she had been
married in Brooklyn,
but she taken her wedding ring off
because she really didn't want them
to know she was married
because then they would know
that she was going back
to America forever.
It was just there so I needed to put
a story like that to give a sense
of what was happening in the house.
I used that story.
I took it precisely from memory.
I remember the woman coming, her
scarves, her hat, she had not been
in the house before , I
knew what her name was,
I knew where her she lived, I
just put it in as a small detail
at the beginning of the story.
And then I found myself
rereading the first chapter
and when I saw those four or five
sentences about her daughter,
I realized that was a story and
that I said I would do anything
to stop Nora Webster.
So I stopped and thought this little
story about a young girl going
to Brooklyn and coming home.
And of course once more
the emotion that has been
with me just before I started to
write the idea of homesickness,
the idea of what morning
sounds are like in a country
that is not a familiar country.
The idea of never being sure and,
for example, am you know if you go
to Ireland I mean it's changing now,
but if you would go in the morning
to get a cup of coffee and
the man might say to you
or the woman behind the counter are
you going to have the coffee here
or are you going to
take away with you?
And you'd say, oh, oh, I think
I'll take it away with me,
but in America, in Austin,
it to go or to stay.
I didn't know what that
meant at beginning.
I would say, oh, and then I'd have
to make a quick decision
you mean the coffee?
Coffee. Oh, I don't know.
And they'd look at you
what you don't know?
Almost every day and, you know, also
that you drive on the wrong side
of the road here, which is very
disturbing for somebody you know,
and these are just two small
examples of the ways in which,
you know, it takes you a
long time to become familiar.
But I think it's the
things you can't name almost
that make you homesick.
I mean I named bread, I named radio
but just a feeling in the air,
a sense of familiarity,
a sense for you're away
that every day is a challenge
and there is no ease in the air.
That was with me as something
that I had been living
with for one semester.
I started to put that into the book
and I started to make the character
as I'd made the Henry James
failure from my own failure
or from the judge's failure to
recognize the sheer importance
and worldwide implications
of my novel.
And that so to my own homesickness
made its way into that book,
and so I stopped writing
Nora Webster and when
that book was finished, I
thought that's the end of Ireland.
I thought one more time about
emigration, missing home,
mothers you know, farewells
all the sadnesses of Ireland,
and I thought I, and also people
were complaining to me that the girl
in my novel, Brooklyn, was really
passive whereas she was just my
Auntie Harriet.
In other words, my auntie Maeve
would bully my Auntie Harriet
in exactly the same way
as Rose would bully Alesh
[phonetic] in the novel.
She was the younger sister of two
who just the older
sister controls everything
and the younger sister did what she
was told this is what would happen
to the younger sister if you
moved her away from that control
that she would still seem
somebody was easy to control,
who was easy to manage, but I begun
to think I better not do that again
and also I was really one more
mention of Enniscorthy where I'm
from and where the
novels had been set,
I thought I need to
leave all that now.
Maybe I'll just to stop altogether
and then suddenly it occurred
to me just like the Henry
James after the other book
that if the Virgin Mary as
an old woman got to speak,
she might have something
very interesting to say.
Once that occurred to me
I just started writing
that down what she would say.
And of course, and that became a
novel which was called the Testament
of Mary, but all the
time I was meant
to be writing a novel
called Nora Webster.
And I always had it there,
you know, in another words,
if the publisher had said no
one wants a novel at the moment
about the Virgin Mary, I mean there
really isn't a need for such a book.
I would've said well, I have
another novel just ready.
And eventually I thought I should
finish the book and because it was
such a personal story, and I
was putting everything into it
that had happened and sometimes
I was using the smallest detail
of that we came back one
night from being away,
from being at my Auntie
Maeve's house
and my mother said there's one
film on, there was only one channel
on television there's a
film on tonight and, boys,
maybe you can stay up late
and watch it called Gaslight.
I'll never forget it because
the three of us, my mother,
my younger brother and myself
got so frightened by the film.
My mother had remembered it as
Ingrid Bergman and something
about glamour and with
Charles Boyer and it was, well,
we thought it was about us.
We thought it was about a
frightened woman in a house
because you know often my mother
would get up in the night and myself
and my younger brother
would hear her
and so those things I was putting
into the book which were, you know,
absolutely from memory coming.
I wasn't transforming and
giving it to Henry James,
I wasn't transforming
and giving them
to an Irish woman whose
was emigrating,
I was actually recording
them all as they occurred
as though I had taken a photograph
or as though I could take a
photograph still as though black
and white photography if I could get
that moment and film it and show it
to you exactly what
it was like as myself
and my younger brother just moved
closer and closer and closer
to my mother as Ingrid
Bergman got more
and more nervous on the television.
I bet if you look back at
the listings for probably
like February 1968 you'd
find that one Sunday night
at about 9 o'clock they showed
Gaslight on Irish television
because we certainly watched it.
And then the problem arose once
more when that book was finished
as to what to do, as to, I felt I
had drained myself out of books,
that by writing that story I had
written in a way my own story
and that in a way what's
strange about childhood
and maybe what stranger even still
about childhood trauma is nothing
as important ever happens
again it is
as though nothing ever
happens again.
So as you dealt with that it is as
though there's nothing else to deal
with and then as usual
something occurred to me.
There was, I just need to say
something first about the whole idea
of what has happened with religion
in Ireland that when I was growing
up I mean there were some
Protestants in Enniscorthy,
but we were mainly
Catholic and everybody,
people were always
going to confession.
You go over on a Saturday and
the whole town will be waiting
at various confession boxes
on two sides and people would,
one priest could be very difficult.
My mother went once and told the
priest that she couldn't think that,
she said she didn't commit
any sin and she couldn't think
of any sin she committed, but
she had to go to confession
because that's what you had to do.
So she couldn't think
so she just said, well,
one night I forgot to
say my night prayers.
And there was a very stern
silence on the other side
and the priest said, you forgot
to say your night prayers?
Are you a mother?
A nice mother he said
as though somehow
or other she must be
a very bad mother,
a nice mother he said sarcastically,
meaning that she couldn't
be a good mother
because she had forgotten
once to say her night prayers.
But people told those sort of
stories about confessions, you know,
some priests were hard,
but that began to disappear
and suddenly it was penance, you
know, everyone's sins were forgiven
by a priest in the top of the altar.
You didn't have to go to the priest,
sit in the confessional or kneel
in the confession box and tell him,
you know, I told a lie, Father,
and he said what sort of lie.
That was over.
They also abolished limbo,
which I thought was quite
a nice thing at the time.
I mean there was, you know,
there was heaven, there was hell,
there was purgatory, but
then there was just limbo
where nothing much happened.
I thought that might be a nice place
because you wouldn't have all the
pressures of all the other places
and they actually abolished
it, it didn't happen anymore.
But there was something
interesting that I discovered
that also disappeared, which was a
whole idea of animism or paganism
that had survived within
Irish Catholicism.
For example, it was said that
if someone in a family was going
to die a knock would come
to the door, just a knock,
and you would hear
it and it would be
at a strange time and
you would know.
And recently I went to see the
house where my grandmother was born,
and I realized it was away from the
main road, it was way down a lane.
Of course, a knock in the
night, a knock on the door
in the night would be the
most astonishing idea.
But then I remembered
asking when did that stop?
I mean that, no one, moving
into the 1980s no one talked
about that anymore and so just,
I'm going to read a small bit
from this novel, House of
Names, where I'm going to,
with Clytemnestra, and whose
husband and Agamemnon has,
he has invoked the gods because
he wants the winds to change
for the beginning of the Trojan
war and the gods have said
if you sacrifice your own
daughter the winds will change.
So he invites his wife and
his daughter to come yours
and he lures them there,
he sacrifices the daughter.
This is the mother in the
aftermath of this where she thinks
about the idea of asking
the gods for things.
I had spies to tell me
when he would come back.
Men lit each fire that gave
the news to further hills
where other man lit
fires to alert me.
It was the fire that brought
the news, not the gods.
Among the gods now there's no
one who offers me assistance
or overseas my actions
or knows my mind,
there is no one among the
gods to whom I appeal.
I live alone in the
shivering solitary knowledge
that the time of the
gods has passed.
I am praying to no gods.
I'm alone among those here because I
do not pray, I will not pray again.
Instead I will speak
in ordinary whispers.
The gods have their
own unearthly concerns,
they barely know we are alive for
them if they were to hear of us,
we would be like the mild sound
of wind in the trees, a distant
and persistent rustling sound.
I know that it was not always thus.
There was a time when the gods
came in the morning to wake us
and they combed our hair and filled
our mouths with the sweetness
of speech and listened
to our desires
and tried to fulfill them for us.
When in your minds and when
they could send us signs.
Not long ago within our memories
the crying women could be heard
in the night and the time
before death came as a way
of calling the dying home
hastening their flight,
softening their wavering
journey to the place of rest.
My husband was with me in the
days before my mother died,
and we both heard it and my mother
heard it too and it comforted her
that death was ready
to lure with its prize.
That noise has stopped.
There's no more crying
like the wind.
The dead fade in their own time.
No one helps them.
No one notices except
those who have been close
to them during their
short spell in the world.
As they fade from the
earth, the gods do not hover
over with their haunting
whistling sound.
I noticed that here the
silence around death.
They have departed the
ones who oversaw death.
They have gone and
they will not be back.
And this is another illustration
of the idea that I've talked
about before of the, of using
things, whatever is on your mind
in the case of the Henry James, in
the case of the going to Brooklyn,
in the case of exile, but
also in this time where a time
of faith clashes with
the time where faith is,
or at least where certain sorts of
rituals are beginning to change.
And so, although this
novel is ostensibly set
in ancient Greece it's also set in
Ireland in which I was brought up
and the Ireland in which I live.
I think we have might have time
now for one or two questions
if anyone has anything to ask me
I will try and tell the truth.
[ Applause ]
>> I have just returned from
Enniscorthy and all the people
at Wilton Garden send
their best to you.
It was a wonderful visit
and a wonderful place
and your influence
is there in big form.
And if we take another 10
or 15 years in Ireland,
which certainly seems robust,
appears robust in its economy,
its literature, what do you see over
the next few decades for Ireland?
>> Colm Toibin: I'm going suppose
the big issue that's facing us now
is [audible] where people
talk about a hard border.
Well, I wrote a book
about the border.
There are 200 ways of
crossing the Irish border.
There are 50 good ways
for a truck to cross.
So if anyone in Brussels or London
thinks that there's just one road
and they can build a wall,
I have news for them.
And also there are plenty of
people around who really would
like to start smuggling again
because there's plenty
of money in smuggling.
So, I suppose that's one area,
but also I think the other area is
that an Ireland or the Republic
of Ireland I think really does feel
a closeness to the European Union
and that there is no appetite
whatsoever in Ireland for us
to join the British in moving
away and becoming an independent,
angry archipelago at
the very edge of things.
So many Irishmen have traveled
in Europe and so many benefitted
from membership with
European Union that I think
that that will become a
stronger bond in the future.
I really love flying over England
and waving at it and saying,
you know, hard luck, guys.
You made a bad deal that time
and also we're really nice.
I mean even Leo Varadkar, our
Prime Minister, said if you want
to come back any time, we'll
help you come back in, you know.
>> Good afternoon.
Thanks for the great talk.
You talked a lot about the changes
in Ireland that have happened.
What continuities to Irish
history have been important
and are important to you as
a writer and as an Irishman.
>> Colm Toibin: Oh,
I think that some
of the continuity would
be interesting
if you could ask the
right questions.
I mean I think the idea of family
is very important, and when we,
when I was involved in the
referendum over gay marriage,
this became a very interesting
business where you probably realize
if you could stop talking
about gay people
as an angry marginalized group who
were different from you but instead
as somebody who could be your
own daughter, your own son,
your own uncle, your own sister,
your own brother, people would go,
oh, well, they're certainly getting
the same rights as everybody else.
And so in that referendum you saw
that sort of loyalty coming where,
I mean you were advised not to go
to the door with your boyfriend
but to bring your aunt,
your mother, your sister,
three of the great talkers of
the family with you and just shut
up just for once if
you're gay shut up.
Let them talk and this
is my son, and he's gay,
his brother is straight, we were all
at his brother's wedding,
it was great.
We'd love to go to his wedding.
Just lend us your vote.
And people say, oh,
and he's your son?
Look at the two of you and
everyone talked about at the door.
People who were going to vote no
saying, oh, if that's the case,
you know, I'll think about
it because I wouldn't
like you to feel left out.
And that intense loyalty around
family I think has still remained,
and I think it's very important.
It's something you see at
Christmas, when, for example,
people come in from America
or come in from Poland,
or I think that's why the Poles
have, the Polish people have come
to live in Ireland have
functions they want
to go home for Christmas too.
We understand that about them
and so that, the whole idea
of belonging not just to Ireland
but to a place in Ireland.
In other words, that you're from.
Where are you from?
Oh, you're from Enniscorthy.
That sort of says something
about you.
So all of that sense of belonging
and family I think has
absolutely remained intact
and despite all the other changes
and, in fact, may even be stronger.
So I mean that's one good thing
that has happened despite, you know,
some of the things that I could.
Also, the roads are better, you
know, and so it's much easier
to get home and sometimes
it's much easier to get away.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much everybody.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us@loc.gov.